being a father is truly the most
important job I've ever had and anyone
who's a father knows it is a job
Gretchen Rossi reveals her partner Slade
Smiley's son Grayson has died he was 22
years old once you put your jammies on
we're gonna brush her teeth I love
spending time with my boys that's the
best part of my day
hey
Housewives of Orange County Alum shared
the sad news on Instagram paying tribute
to Grayson who died following his battle
with brain cancer which he was first
diagnosed with in 2006 next to a
slideshow of photos with the family
Gretchen writes we are Beyond devastated
and heartbroken over the loss of gray
Grayson Arroyo Smiley was such a special
human being guess what that means that
means you get to wash your hands again
dude hey hey this is a very important
rule Gretchen adds he was an angel on
this Earth and an incredible Warrior a
warrior like no one has ever seen before
he fought every day through his pain and
discomfort to find joy in the smallest
of things he was a true Beacon of light
and hope slate is the best dad ever he's
just
incredible dad
went in love with his little princess
Gretchen and Slade who've been together
for 13 years share a three-year-old
daughter Skyler gray their daughter's
middle name was chosen in honor of
Grayson Grayson was obviously so excited
about Skyler because we named her Skylar
Gray after Grayson so he was just so so
thrilled about that Grayson's mom and
Slade's ex-wife Michelle Arroyo also
confirmed her son's death on Instagram
Michelle says she's still in shock but
takes comfort in knowing Grayson's now
in a better place playing cards with his
grandma and hanging with his dog MO
[Music]